usted o alguien que usted quiere puede
haber sido diagnosticado con cáncer de
pulmón este vídeo le ayudará a entender
algunas de las opciones de tratamiento
disponibles
el cáncer de pulmón es una enfermedad en
la cual se forman células cancerosas en
los tejidos pulmonares
los dos tipos principales de cáncer de
pulmón son el cáncer no microcítico de
células no pequeñas de pulmón y el
cáncer microcítico de células pequeñas
de pulmón el cáncer pulmonar no
microcítico tiene nueve opciones de
tratamiento estándar cirugía
radioterapia quimioterapia
terapia dirigida inmunoterapia
terapia de láser terapia fotodinámica
crioterapia electro cauterización y
espera con observación hay varios tipos
de cirugía según el tamaño y la
localización del tumor y el estado de
funcionamiento de los pulmones
durante un tipo de cirugía llamada
cirugía de resección en cuña se extrae
una pequeña parte del pulmón
[Música]
en otro tipo de cirugía llamada
lobectomía se quita un pedazo más grande
del pulmón llamado lóbulo
durante una neumonía se retira un pulmón
completo
y en una recepción el manguito el médico
puede extraer una parte de los bronquios
si el cáncer se encuentra en sus vías
respiratorias
otra opción de tratamiento es la terapia
de radiación se usa radiación para
destruir células cancerosas o impedir
que crezcan
[Música]
y la radioterapia de as externo utiliza
una máquina que dirige la radiación
hacia el cáncer desde fuera del cuerpo
la radioterapia de as interno utiliza
una sustancia que emite radiación
las sustancias se colocan dentro del
cuerpo cerca del cáncer
y la quimioterapia combate el cáncer
mediante el uso de fármacos
estos medicamentos pueden tratar todo el
cuerpo o pueden tratar un área
la terapia dirigida usa fármacos que se
dirigen a las células cancerosas
específicas estos fármacos evitan que
las células cancerosas crezcan y se
dividan
debido a que estos medicamentos afectan
principalmente las células cancerosas
hay menos daño a las células normales
y la inmunología también conocida como
inmunoterapia ayuda a su sistema
inmunitario a combatir el cáncer el
cáncer a veces se puede ocultar de las
células inmunitarias que lo atacan
por ejemplo tanto el cáncer como las
células inmunitarias pueden tener
proteínas llamadas proteínas de punto de
control cuando éstas se adhieren las
otras células inmunitarias detienen su
ataque algunos medicamentos de
inmunoterapia contra el cáncer de pulmón
evitan que las proteínas de punto de
control se adhieran entre sí como
resultado las células inmunitarias
pueden atacar y destruir las células
cancerosas
en la terapia con láser un haz de luz
intenso quema el tejido canceroso
y la terapia fotodinámica utiliza un
fármaco activado por la luz
una vez que el medicamento se introduce
en el cuerpo éste se acumula en las
células cancerosas
luego se insertan tubos de fibra óptica
en el cuerpo cerca del tumor la luz del
láser se envía a través de los tubos la
luz activa el fármaco
y el fármaco activado mata a las células
cancerosas
durante la crioterapia el tejido
canceroso se congela y destruye
en la electro cauterización un
instrumento calentado quema y destruye
el tejido canceroso
y por último la espera vigilante se hace
en ciertos casos de cáncer no
microcítico de pulmón
su médico vigila de cerca su afección
hasta que los síntomas se presenten o
cambien
y las principales opciones de
tratamiento para el cáncer microcítico
de pulmón son dos de las mismas que se
usan para tratar el cáncer no
microcítico de pulmón la quimioterapia y
la radioterapia
para cualquiera de los tipos de cáncer
de pulmón el médico puede prescribir una
combinación de tratamientos
si tiene alguna pregunta sobre el cáncer
de pulmón o sobre cualquier medicamento
que le hayan recetado consulte a su
médico es importante que tomen sus
medicamentos según las indicaciones y
que informe cualquier efecto secundario
que tenga